c'est donc ici au bord de cette petite
route que la dizaine de témoins a pu
observer le phénomène alors comment ça
s'est passé en revue ensemble en même
temps exactement en même temps et en
même temps une double exclamations mais
qu'est ce que c'est que cela qu'est ce
que c'est que cela je sais que ce gros
machin qui l'aurait dit derrière qui
étaient des pattes d'araignée
alors ça dégager comme du gaz et des
machettes papier qu'exploiter dérives et
j'étais absolument hypnotisé par cet
objet insolite
lorsque chimène ne prend pas loin je
regarde ce qu'il ya là bas nous avons
regardé alors là franchement nous avons
eu peur l'un et l'autre mais vraiment
peur car les trois objets qui apparaît
c'est à l'horizon était en tout point
semblable au premier
ils sont venus à peu près opinions d'un
axe du pignon oui c'est cela on arrive
qui les amuse et ils s'amusent ensemble
alors des mouvements symétrique
verticales horizontales verticales
horizontales quel est le bruit que vous
avez entendu est ce que c'est un
sifflement sa collègue reichmann
vas-y que je te pousse
lorsqu'au moment précis où il semblait
que tout allait s'effondrer au milieu
d'un choc effroyable le premier objet
monter en altitude c'est la première
fois plus élevé mais ce pas il est monté
avec une vitesse extraordinaire j'estime
à plus de deux milles à l'heure au bout
d'un moment on n'a plus vu qu'un seul
petit point noir et j'ai dit à chimène
cette fois ça y est le spectacle est
terminé et vous vous avez des années
après non quand ses roquettes vous non
pas des drogues en a bien quelques uns
qui disait on à une désillusion en ciel
on ne peut pas parler d'hallucinations